thank you
I would be deadly serious here I've not
been this excited ever wow
you know that you're part of History
buffing the system everybody needs to
tell your friends your family your
neighbors hey you want a second American
Revolution you don't like what's
happening well this is the group this is
the organization that is the best there
is and how you tune into my show you're
going to get hardcore analysis and Over
the Horizon information on what the
globalist you're planning next that's
all I do is study it it's hardcore
because our business is prosperity and
freedom and Justice and Americana 7
sick worldwide I've been Shadow Man I've
been called a liar I've been silenced on
virtually every platform created by man
my life has been threatened repeatedly
they've tried to destroy me but I've
survived that's why I decided to join
mug Club to be part of this
revolutionary act you want resistance
you want somebody to stand up you want
somebody to fight go now to the Mud Club
take action because the globalists want
war they will destroy us well guess what
we didn't start this fight we don't want
it but if you want to fight you better
believe you've got on
Alex Jones everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder with
crowder.com mug Club gain access to an
unrivaled catalog of unapologetic and
entertaining Traders including The
Hodgetwins Nick depalo Brian Callan and
of course Alex Jones all that and
everything you see today is entirely
funded by viewers like you for 89
annually join the fight at louder with
credit.com mug club today
[Music]
[Applause]
bring up
you will be successful
you know you missed the Sip because
third chair won't shut the house
oh my gosh you're so excited don't give
him that heart of a Time
I haven't introduced him yeah you're
still talking still with the talking
sorry
shut up can I may I do the sipping
please please
now great just got third degree burns
because I rushed it
create start hey that's because we have
a very very busy week next week just so
you know first off we have Alex Jones's
show launched this week so I'm saying
the next the next seven days very busy
this Friday boom also our show Friday if
you're not a member of mug Club so we're
doing five shows a week you got Alex
Jones got Nick de Paulo four days a week
feel better Nick he's been a little bit
under the weather then on Monday we are
going to be releasing the first black
and white and the gray issues it's
pretty simple on the street talk with
black guys that's it
sweet as a white guy why you'll be
shocked as to how much Common Ground you
find as a white Christian conservative
uh with the average black American who
has lived what the left calls the
so-called black experience right I don't
know if van Jones is right now or Joy
Reid but it's a great experience and uh
next what we'll be doing in a barber
shop I think we're missing each other we
need to keep speaking with each other
then Gerald is going to Milwaukee we're
doing a live debate stream on uh
Wednesday Night Live tune in for that
and we will have the candidates we'll
have a mug Club Booth down there in
Milwaukee
so a lot of stuff going on next week
this week
I'm angry because apparently now we've
you know you've lost the words
[Music]
foreign
so we'll be talking about that Maui
you've been lied to three key facts it
gets to be white noise I understand it
we're distilling it down to three key
facts you need to know climate change is
not Chief amongst them it's not amongst
them at all
those facts will be stunned to find out
that climate change is not amongst them
and uh we'll also be announcing some
contest winners here on the show Gerald
a number two CEO how are you I am doing
well I'd love it when you're a little
prickly
Joe Lewis woke me up at 2 30 a.m which
because you know he doesn't bark yeah
he's not a barker and he his hair was up
he was his ears were up and it sounded
like there were people in the house or
there's this weird area of my
neighborhood where it echoes right and
uh they were doing like some work on the
street and stuff like that so I woke up
so I got about two hours of sleep but I
I had to encourage him because I don't
want to lose that right so the guy
showed up on time I pay them to walk you
up in the middle of the night just to
piss you off well I encourage him
because I want him to mess someone up if
they do well that's true yeah I never
want to lose that no 100 yeah good boy
Joe Lewis we'll bring him in on mug club
and then when you hear this you know who
it is
oh look at that yeah nothing like
revealing the lead uh
Thursday Friday Saturday August 24th
through the 26th is going to be Laugh
Out Loud Comedy Club in San Antonio and
his show starts here September 1st on
Mud Club the Brian calendar Mr Brian
Callan how are you I'm just a man my
friend wearing this blue which yeah I
think tempers the hatred in my eyes I
hope man we're using that term loose
which oh come on now by the way I was in
your house last night I like to watch it
oh well I know so
I threw Joe Lewis a treat he loves you I
know you sleep deep you sleep you play
dirty Brian you play dirty that's not
fair I do I know I need my sleep I like
to pick locks and ninja creepy some
people call it beauty sleep I call it
staving off death sleep
just doing my best I have all these
things on my Instagram about reverse
aging I don't know if you know this
another bull crap all right it doesn't
work nope so let's go right into it
Donald Trump right some people call him
former presidents some people refer to
him as sitting president I call him
sitting president okay so Donald Trump
uh is going to be hosting a live stream
on Monday uh regarding Georgia and uh
the safest and most secure oh that's
right YouTube now allows us to I can say
that the biggest election of
our time
uh so he is going to be doing a live
stream on Monday now he also responded
in his latest indictment here to Georgia
uh and then he put something on Truth
social which they're now accusing of
being racist surprise so let's first
watch a clip of his press conference
that took place I believe uh on Monday I
challenged the election in Georgia which
I have every right to do which I was
right about frankly
and they want to indict me because I
challenge the election did they have
this crap going on I just never even
thought of this one Trump didn't really
believe he won the election let me tell
you people that know me say that's one
thing I tell you there was never a
second of any day that I didn't believe
that that election was remember I told
you nothing else matters if he believed
it was a rigged election but there are
Shenanigans there's nothing illegal
election and this country should be a
shame and they go after the people that
want to prove that it was rigged and
stolen so it never happens that they go
after them they don't go after the
people that rigged it okay and we'll see
how it all turns out you know
do you hear that hold on faintly in the
distance it's the sound of of DeSantis
soiling his panties
I love the way that he just one of these
things I never even thought for any
second
and then they go after the people can
you believe it well it's important
though because in the indictment if they
can prove that he said I actually don't
believe this or if if they can prove
that he at any time said they absolutely
won the election they can't if they do
that then then he would be considered
making false statements right exactly
with an election but he's like we say
they can't find them we talked about
this on Monday if he believed as many of
you right you can hit like if you're
watching on YouTube or Rumble I
recommend you watch on Rumble if you
think that the election had some
discrepancies at least if you're one if
he thought that then he was trying to
preserve our Republic if he was lying
and he didn't think that there was any
Foul Play then they would have a case I
can tell you having been in
communication with many people not and I
don't just I don't mean Donald Trump
directly but people who were looking
into the election uh every single one
saw the discrepancies not a single one
was like now people can be wrong there's
a huge difference between being wrong
and lying being wrong is not a crime and
I don't believe that they were wrong no
look just hear me out everyone who came
forward with affidavits or evidence they
were largely dismissed they didn't run
the investigations properly just to be
clear so it's one of those things you
can't really prove that it's wrong
because you don't want to prove that
it's wrong you just want to say it's
wrong and here's Donald Trump's
statement on Truth social this is this
is what brings us here to the
racist giant loud whistle okay
a large complex detailed but irrefutable
report on the presidential election
fraud which took place in Georgia my
favorite Georgia
it's on my mind they say I got it I
caught a Midnight Train To it frankly
is almost complete will be presented by
me at a major news conference at 11 A.M
on Monday of next week in Bedminster New
Jersey
based on the results of this conclusive
all caps report all charges should be
dropped against me and others there will
be a complete exoneration folks they
never went after those that rigged the
election they only went after those that
fought to find the riggers and that is
now everything catches fire yes exactly
so the in-cross is everywhere yeah he
said it the independent said that Donald
Trump called out for racist dog whistle
in the apostrophe quotes at these in
rent against Georgia prosecutors yeah
political analysts whatever that means
uh Ariah cobbler kovler said I don't
know if Trump deliberately uses riggers
as a dog whistle but his supporters hear
it either way they're going after you
he's just in the way yeah then you have
another author Keith Boykin saying that
Donald Trump says he wants to find the
rigors Trump's choice of words is Not an
Accident after spending days making
racist attacks against Fannie Willis
what then there was a podcast that said
Michael Cohen told us that Trump used
the n-word ah great hey look except it
was an R hold on hold on you mean the
lawyer the disgrace lawyer that went to
jail yes that guy he said that Donald
Trump used the n-word now he has a new
favorite word guess what it is riggers
hey anyone there who lives in the South
you ever heard of chiggers oh my God
comment below remember the first time
yeah I had to go and ask for the
be gone whatever off whatever
the hell it's called they get under your
skin and it was an Asian pharmacist
and she was from New Jersey so she was
not familiar and she popped up huh
it's like no no no it's a thing it's a
thing so now is it anything that rhymes
with a racial epithet
and then they say yeah Michael Cohen
told us that he used the n-word
therefore he's a racist but hold on a
second you made that up that's what they
do they make it up and then try and sit
you down in court and say oh did you say
this person says you use the n-word yeah
that's because that piece of said
that
yeah
and you believed it you must be
confusing me with that piece of
laughs
oh my gosh riggers so of course they've
always accused him of racist dog
whistles right remember when I said he
nicknamed Leticia James peekaboo he said
Six Theories as to why and of course
they were all about racism remember the
Independence that Mary Trump says she
heard the president use the n-word and
anti-semitic slurs as a White House
claims she's lying Mary Trump who has
come out and tried to slander him so
many times yeah I'm gonna believe a word
she says yeah by the way record black
vote just to be clear change the
electoral map he'll be surprised again
black and white in the gray issues it
comes out money you'll be surprised what
the average black American
uh thinks about Donald Trump you'll be
surprised what the average black
American thinks about the state of this
country and if they are proud to be a
citizen of this country
hint they don't share a lot in common
with white Suburban women now the term
is riggers to be clear that's what
people are upset about uh saying that
it's a racist dog whistle and a spirit
of full disclosure to be fair
there have been instances where that
term has been used for a while and
contextually
it may have a point
hey the sheriff is a rich
[Music]
it's commuting licensing to be clear
only they can say it
figures
who try to read the game they riggers
they ring your ass up
we took a risk
I don't approve I gotta go back to LA
yeah guys that too far guys you don't
bring the Ruckus you're far listen they
made the song not us okay have we made
it better we have clan in their name now
it's not surprising here's where we are
and I hope that you under it's the same
thing with big Tech it doesn't matter
how much you couch your words they're
going to accuse you of it anyway Yep
they're going to say racism they're
going to say sexism they're going to say
transphobia whatever the hell that means
they're experts at this seems to me you
are the expert Mark name that movie line
coffee is racist all references are
available at lettuce credit.com I'm not
making this up camping is racist air is
racist hot weather is racist manners are
racist the nuclear family is racist
waking up early is racist exercising is
racist gardening is racist bicycling is
racist now spaces on college campuses
segregated exclusively by race to be
clear
well it's Progressive
[Laughter]
I love this by the way for him not do
you understand have you not been
watching Donald Trump for the last I
don't know ever especially the last five
six seven years of his life do you think
there is one part of him that would ever
think that he didn't win the election
even if it was a landslide in the
opposite direction
I want it he was saying it before
there's no way on earth that is
hilarious to me that you would think
that Donald Trump of all people would
not think that he won the election yeah
he is the only person on the planet who
could have thought that and he would
have been convinced of it yeah even if
it was wrong and in this case he's not
it doesn't I appreciate your boldness
yes you're my rigor
[Laughter]
not your work yeah that's right well you
know what I just made it my word wow
yeah I generally so forceful so dominant
I Jerry curled the rigor's word he lives
the way he sleeps
in objects Terror
so we're live streaming the debate by
the way I don't think Donald Trump
president Donald Trump is going to be
there Wednesday night August 23rd we
will have uh these people anyone who has
the balls to sit down on this show we
don't do the talking points we'll have a
mug Club booth there of course Rumble is
supporting it yeah uh here's something
else you you look like you're live so
you probably like swimming I am live
yeah a little too uh Shredded guys I
usually I sink but yeah yeah you've got
good uh it's tough when you're that
muscles but you are lat dominant I am
right now I can't believe you said that
it's true
I do this I I Glide
I know it's hold on hold on by the way
that right there what that's years of
practice no one does that little
that's why I was about to ask well
because that's how you show the obliques
yeah but Brian how do you hide them yeah
that's a good question impossible two
shirts two American shirts we're trying
to show us how you glide through the air
and you just wanted to do the shimmy you
wouldn't do that falling through the
there you adjust to yeah well that's how
that's that's how I set myself through
college you wanted to do it that was his
nickname the sugar glider
and now welcome to the stage sugar
glider this kid needs help with his rent
boys yeah actually worked at
Chippendales but it didn't really work
because he actually tried to be uh
correct biologically like he was in any
he came out they said sugar glider he
went
he just came out and started telling
jokes this isn't sexy at all
glider are we going to the marsupial fan
like come on just be accurate we can't I
can't dance I can binomial nomenclature
all right speaking of things that make
no sense if you believe in science not
the science science
October the world uh Aquatics they'll
host the First Swim competition I have
to read this because I still don't
believe it
featuring an open category now what that
means is um just to be clear uh chicks
with wieners so trans athletes here's
them announcing it new plans to
nothing
with the organization overseeing that
internationally announcing plans for an
open category for Trans athletes to
participate they're trying to balance
the concerns of people who are concerned
about access for trans women to sports
and as well as concerns about you know
fairness in sports when you have some
women some trans women who are doing
very well now research has found that
trans women do not tend to dominate
what's so funny they can't not step on
themselves because some women some trans
women and then there's a then there's an
author a reporter who's going to say
trans women are just women don't say
trans women
just just take my livelihood please I I
just couldn't get my eyes off his his
he's got those eyebrows he's so
surprised he had his brows done yeah
well he looks like a marionette yeah he
looks like he's always surprised he
looks like he should start every phrase
what a loser
yeah
[Applause]
no yeah he looks like an athlete here's
the thing
we already have a special category in
swimming for those missing parts of
their body
yeah it just if there's something
different about what he does to the
others isn't there but you can see this
that he goes deeper for a start he comes
up pretty much level but it's this this
is I don't know what he does I don't
know how he does it and it's glorious
high five uh everybody here is going to
hell well so we'll just know that he's
he's the River Styx Champion we showed
them doing very well yes he's the river
sticks Champion by the way and also I
didn't get that Greek mythology
you found uh there was also a cyclist
they do armless cycling and well this is
true it was a paralympic cycling and his
he had no arms in the award for winning
was a watch
I'm not making this one look up so
research again paralympic cyclist given
watch you can wear it on your ankle or
you can wear it on your camera but he
was mad really just because it was a
Casio
I feel like walking up to the podium
you're like oh crap so just just to be
clear what they'll always say there
there's no clear uh biological Advantage
right that's what they uh first off
that's untrue and when I say this I mean
you know basic things like bone density
muscle mass lung capacity all of this
not to mention your hormonal levels but
there are clear concrete examples it's
the reverse Nirvana fallacy well it
hasn't there hasn't been a problem yet
therefore it must be perfect if it
happens there won't be a problem that's
because there aren't enough trans people
in the world and there aren't enough
people yet who figured out how to game
the system of the people who have the
percentage the winning percentage of
trans male athletes and female sports is
incredible of course you know Leah
Thomas right right top times in the NCAA
Women's 200 meter and the 500 meter that
by the way is a man would be 893rd best
and 501st best that's I don't know I'm
not a mathematician but that's a 500
spaces below number one that's insane I
had no idea it took five hold on hold on
893rd in the world or in this class for
200 meter and first in the championship
I saw 501st in the 500 meter and first
in the women's yeah see the difference
it's not small and that's just the one
you know about because Leah Thomas likes
the Limelight you know as a lot of
narcissists do but yeah cycling you have
Rachel McKinnon biological male one
Women's Championship set the world
record high school track Terry Miller
won two state titles at the 2018
Connecticut state track championships
trans athletes that make about 1.2
percent of all high school athletes uh
and then they win a disproportionate
percentage so Terry Miller by the way
won 67 of the events she competed in on
Monday the Canadian trans power lifter
and Andre set the Canadian national
record for women's deadlift and uh by
the way had just consumed four beers
oh I think I trusted by over 400 pounds
yes it was this one amazing like it
wasn't even close like just destroyed it
he didn't even use smelling salts
by the way we do have the clip of the uh
the the the cyclist yeah well we are
going to
[Music]
you're all terrible we're not terrible
they're terrible place that person to
watch I bet you that guy finds it funny
well he'll sell it he's a huge ladder
with Crowder fans yeah fight like hell
under we're not Jersey we're not making
fun of him for his like obviously
terrible issue that he's had to deal
with however that happened we're making
fun of them forgive and watch it also
came with gloves
and that's that's where I draw the line
change the prize just it's your fault
not ours yes change it he knew the prize
going into the race come on come on
change it to nub warmers he's always had
a dream because he was a young child yes
I've always wanted to win a watch sir
yes we'd like Rolex to sponsor the
armless cycling category what Brian
nothing you're about to say something I
wanted to raise some kind of I wanted to
be uh I wanted to raise objections but I
had nothing witty to say yeah what's
okay because you know what there can be
no objections that's objectively funny
and that's objectifying a guy with no
arms that's what I said I'm not
objectifying it I'm exalting it they
were how dare they figured out a way to
use a wrist watch yeah he's the MacGyver
of the nubbies
limb different yes exactly did the bike
have long handles how do they do that
Brian don't ask cycle don't ask these
questions I have questions how they
select the events at the Paralympics
someone can answer honestly if you've
competed at the Paralympics uh how like
I know there's wheelchair basketball
okay right yeah but what if there's a
guy who does have some kind of physical
disability but it's not a wheelchair
it's like well there's no basketball for
you yeah you got to be wheel you got to
be a wheelchair guy for basketball it's
like but I want to play basketball and
I'm missing an arm do we have one-handed
basketball it's wheelchair basketball
it's all about wheelchair basketball
these days armless is swimming you can
swim or you can cycle but you cannot
play basketball yeah all right
wheelchair boxing I don't know if they
have boxing I don't know what these
since when did we need to make up these
different categories for people I'm
sorry I know the trans thing we actually
talked about this we said look if you
want to compete yeah fine you got to
compete in your biological sex so they
can make this other category nobody's
gonna care like fi you know what make an
open category for steroids as well let
anybody who wants to compete no matter
at least they are doing an open category
yeah no rules that's fine hey how much
you want to bet the open category won't
be won by a woman
that's the only thing we do know a lot
of variables except that you can
eliminate that one won't be a woman zero
women will win that competition and if
you're offended by that okay I'm gonna
put you on the spot here all right
someone says uh you either you either
win a million dollars you win a billion
dollars or if you lose your whole family
dies okay we have a lineup here it's
five women five average men who's going
to win a pull-up competition
gas with the digs
the guys just stop it why did you have
to be specific pretzels that you twist
yourselves into and by the way that's
also limb different phobic because they
can't twist themselves there's no Yogi
Bear who's Lim different hey we have
limb different that's the term that's
the term people got in trouble we
announced a contest and now we have the
winner ah winner for newest non-mug club
members we asked you to write a tweet
explaining uh what the idea of mug Club
meant to you use the hashtag mug Club
giveaway we'll be continuing to do it
into next week and uh the winners are
going to be gifted a free year of mug
clubs here's winner number one Caleb FB
333 said mud clip to me is for free
thinkers we are constantly bombarded
with rhetoric from mass media who bend
over backwards for the corrupt
government big Tech and the narratives
they push mug Club is fighting against
that thank you very much absolutely get
a free free of the mug Club you want to
read the next one there Gerald ah didn't
know who you were talking to oh what
does Mud Club mean to me working in a
stressful job with chronically ill
patients who are transitioning into end
of life I look forward to your shows
each day while I love your candor your
humor helps me to focus on something
more positive like Brian Collins lats
what kind of job is that where you're
working with chronically ill people uh
it's hospice
nurse what I thought the employees were
crying the woman's the Saints
where is this employees so with Leprosy
time to take your pills
a leper colony
I thought I was gonna go to hospice no
that's us
speaking of limbless why am I paying
yeah it's a write-off
well you get a free year of my club
thank you very much good for you spots
on your skin let's go to Maui if you've
been following this the fires sorry yeah
yeah I'm not going to Maui sorry I'm not
laughing about the fires so
[Laughter]
now look yes because it's obvious
there's nothing there's nothing funny no
there's not it was something else yeah
too much wild crap I hope she's not
somebody transitioning to end of life
otherwise might not be a full year so
okay oh right you just you had to
everyone here just I wonder
it's the river sticks bound it's a live
show by the way Monday through Thursday
10 a.m Eastern here the free portion
then you can continue watching on mug
clip today's chat Thursday so in Maui
now let me ask you this
with Maui um
what do you believe is the biggest
contributing factor here and I would
like for you when you contrast that with
what the media has told you is the
biggest contributing factor of course
you know it's climate change because
they're dicks now
yeah
here's the problem with that let's sort
of let's sort of amplify the idea of you
know the LIE of riggers well what ends
up happening when you say everything's
This Racist dog whistle it's not true
the LIE creates black lives matter riots
and billions of dollars in Damages and
you know thousands of casualties just to
be clear and so what happens when you
lie about climate change is more people
die because you don't prepare for these
problems in the future if you cannot
properly address the problem then you're
of no use now take that and add a few
trillion dollars and you get our
government so in Maui death toll is over
100 it's terrible it's a tragedy 1300
are still missing but there are three
key facts that you need we know what has
happened now just to be clear there is
no doubt and we'll get into it but first
let me refresh your memory today marks
one week since the wildfires tore
through Lahaina but the search and
recovery for victims is just in the
beginning stages the death toll stands
at nearly 100 but that number is
expected to grow dramatically in the
coming days the National Guard and 20
cadaver dogs continue the painstaking
search for victims now here's an actual
video title from a local Miami ABC
affiliate wildfires in Maui about 1300
vanished at least 96 dead I'm sorry what
1300 vanished yeah vanished vanished
that's an interesting word choice yeah
vanished and here are kind of the three
key facts that you need to know all
right let's go to fast fact number three
and we'll make all these references
publicly available I think you need to
hit uh there Tim yeah number three three
all right
the media is clearly running cover here
uh for internet government okay ABC to
give you an example they were forced to
change their headline about the fires
the original headline was why climate
change can't be blamed for Maui
wildfires then they revised it to why
climate change can't be blamed entirely
for the moment right
it can't be blamed uh at all just to be
clear for them not at all
I had no idea that even happened yeah
the amount of manipulation that happens
with the media is insane what you see is
the tip of the iceberg here's uh a fast
fact I guess number two for you this is
where we deal with inept government I
mean especially when you have like just
water that basically disappears that's
like that happened uh we'll get to that
the emergency officials they had it no
experience so according to Nora
O'Donnell there at CBS News CBS News has
learned Maui's Emergency Operations
Chief had no background in Disaster
Response that's what I look for in my
chief exactly it's his Department that
is responsible for setting off warning
sirens which rang silent during the
fires they had warning sirens that
didn't warn
person in charge of them had no business
in that job
government for you
you don't get to fire these people just
to be clear this wasn't an employee that
didn't have any experience and they were
working their way up this was the chief
this was the person solely responsible
at the end of the day for making sure
this was done right and his answer for
why he didn't do it is
terrifying who owned a chief guys it's
not water it's it's I know you're
worried it's a tsunami it's it's not
water but it's fine go back to bed it's
fire yeah it won't hurt you yeah it's a
wave of fire not water you're safe yeah
no need for a siren yeah
we were going to do it but it's a
different sound and I gotta switch it
out and I don't have my iPad yeah I'm
not not Yakuza I can't make that so yeah
uh the chief his name is uh Herman
adanya defended not using the sirens
because yeah didn't want people to think
that's what that was his actual defense
so you're being kind of satirical but uh
he actually said I don't know I didn't
want people to think there was a tsunami
I love that and he's like yeah I don't
want them to run towards the fire yeah
I'm like they would have seen it right
you idiot well right not necessarily
maybe they were sleeping until the fire
was upon them because they weren't uh
awakened from their Slumber yeah because
there was no siren which the taxpayers
by the way they pay for that they're not
paying for you to give free free
internet to someone in Poughkeepsie
they're paying so that you keep them
safe and if you're on an island you know
tsunamis but also fires that can travel
really quickly I certainly think Charlie
Boy that qualifies yeah by the way these
these systems living in Texas we deal
with tornadoes right so they don't just
have Sirens they have things that they
can actually say yes one time yes it was
really ominous outside I walked outside
and I heard seek shelter instead of the
siren and I was like well that's
interesting instead of seeking shelter I
walk to the industry so I can see what
was going on I'm an idiot but
nonetheless
yeah but you can do things like that in
my neighborhood they play The Rolling
Stones Gimme Shelter which is sort of
cryptic cryptic well I will say a
tsunami me siren if you're conditioned
to run away from the water is not what
you you know it's not what you sound
when there are fires because yeah but
you know what the water I understand
your points Counterpoint seems to me if
they have the ability to you know use
Sirens they have a speaker system right
I was gonna say they could maybe be
reading it on the speaker system and say
run toward the
[Applause]
door there's a fire fire hey they're
just going hey um yeah you know how a
lot of you here um don't want uh to be
burned alive yeah yeah well uh if you
want the opposite of that then just to
you know go away from the fire fire get
over water
go toward the waves yeah hope you enjoy
that quarter million pay pay stub so
fast fact uh here key fact I should say
number one again we talked about the
media running cover we've talked about
them having no experience being
completely inept the Water Resources in
this always goes back to now climate
change is not responsible but climate
change activism
and how muddled it has become and how
dishonest is is often responsible
for wildfires you know when they're not
allowed to do controlled up they're not
allowed to carry out controlled Burns in
California a big part of it we've talked
about this was the the dams they can't
build dams because of a smelt which is a
fish that doesn't swim well which should
die
so water resources and there's so much
red tape that happens when you're
dealing with water now because of
climate change record levels I think
last year in the Great Lakes most
important fresh fresh water body in the
country just to be clear they never tell
you that they were being squandered they
weren't being managed properly so in
October 2022 the Hawaii Commission on
Water Resource Management in the the
director was a Kaleo Manuel
said this so don't believe me believe
your lion eyes and ears about Maui's
Water Resources we've become used to
looking at water as like something which
we use and not necessarily something
that we Revere as that thing that gives
us life right I mean to me it's a shift
in value set if we can start to really
look at how we as humans in an island
um Can re-connect to that traditional
value set let water connect us and not
divide us like we we can share it but it
requires true conversations about equity
stupid but connect us and not divide are
you talking about Land Bridge Theory
what the just you're on an island I
tell you there's water water divides you
from everybody it's an island it's a
divider I think we should start drinking
from a communal cup everybody yes
sharing the same water yeah it's not
something it's something that should be
revered again this comes from Pagan
Earth worship think Gaia right Mother
Earth well by the way if that's the case
Mother Earth is a just to be clear
this is not a mother who fully loves you
and takes care of you oh yeah that guy's
never had cholera or Giardia no exactly
water's not your friend yes cholera
you're not from the age of it now he
says it should not be used but revered
that the priority is not that the
resources the Earth by the way animals
as well uh that human beings have
dominion over them and that we should be
responsible it's it is our duty to serve
them that's the difference so when the
left says oh you think that you have
ownership you think that you have
control over animals or whenever a vegan
says that if you're a God-fearing person
yes absolutely this is why it's
antithetical to a Christian worldview we
are supposed to we are called to be
responsible good stewards of our
resources just to be clear but those are
our resources as human beings who have
dominion over the Earth meaning we want
humans to live we want to propagate
think about everything that they push oh
water is something we need to serve
water we need to serve the Earth we need
to serve the great white sharks who are
going larger and more aggressive in Cape
Cod and eating all the fish and people
whereas we believe no no hold on a
second we need to be good we need to be
good stewards of our planet but they
serve us overpopulation every single
issue when it comes to natural resource
management from the left it's
anti-people it is it's anti-people and
it lines up on the side of the earth and
the ecosystem that exists outside of
human beings as though we are not the
apex predator which I would argue light
bulbs so we are
but that deserves priority okay so this
same guy Manuel uh was asked by the way
by the Maui fire department for more
water okay this will piss you off yeah
this is a quote here it says if Maui
fire department had requested permission
he asked them Manuel
if they had uh requested permission to
dip into the reservoirs told them to
inquire with a local farmer first to
check how a diversion of the water
supply would affect him wow how about no
how about no rules there's a fire I'm
putting it out I don't care if it's the
last drop of water and I kill an
endangered species in the process of
saving human lives there's not enough
macadamia nuts in the world Manuel
but he still wants you to poop in water
yes yes
incredible can you believe that that's
the kind of thinking so apparently
climate change did have a bit of a role
in this it infected people's minds yes
and they started thinking more like you
said it's not they're not just putting
those things first and not letting us
have dominion over it they're literally
enacting policies in California Oregon
Washington Canada right now has tons of
wildfires these policies end up killing
people and saving fish yeah think about
that juxtaposition when those decisions
are being made stuff like this a problem
by the way can I add a plus one do you
mind if I had a plus one yeah no go go
go ahead plus one electric company was
actually and is currently actually being
sued because some of this information
actually came out that said they knew
that their power lines were going to be
a problem and could potentially Spark
wildfires years ago right in 2022 they
actually asked for some federal funding
because of this specific problem so that
they could Shore up that and they got it
I don't know if it's actually Federal
maybe it was State funding I think it
was like 198 million dollars that they
were awarded to do it but had not done
anything with it yet this problem was
not an unknown yeah these people did not
have an issue that just surprised them a
wildfire on an island no way no
everybody knew that this was a big
potential risk nobody did anything about
it yeah and and but if you're watching
on Rumble you can smash the rumble
button or hit share on YouTube this is
why I don't agree you can hit that there
this is why I don't agree when people
say you know
I don't believe in any ideology
um I just take issues on an individual
basis no no you need to take the factual
uh the evidence presented on an
individual issue basis of course
but you can't fight what I will argue is
evil ideology with no ideology of your
own you can't fight an ism with only a
few sets of facts you have to present
them right through a lens now here's the
thing for us to get here with Hawaii
they would have to look at these facts
these circumstances in other words none
of this was a surprise right the idea
that these water resources are not you
would have to start off
with government is good and is the
solution to the problem in order to
think that having a massive bloated
government and people without experience
being assigned to Chief roles is a good
idea you would have to start with that
this starts with government needs to
solve these problems government is the
answer got bit more government good and
then you would also need to have the
world view of and Earth is priority
ecosystem over people that's the only
because if you say hold on this defies
reason it does it doesn't defy the
ideological motivations of those people
in charge and you cannot combat them by
saying well hold on a second uh this key
all of these are key facts but to
preemptively combat that you need to
start off with hold on a second my
worldview tells me that no government is
not inherently the answer and that
larger government tends to be
ineffective and lead to corruption
unchecked power leads to unfettered
power to put it simply hold on a second
I believe we should be responsible in
managing our resources but with the key
the North start in mind being in order
to serve Humanity
these aren't odds with each other this
is how we get here it's the same way you
get there with covid
no no government can solve the problem
if you start off with government good
you may not understand that it could
have come in a lot from a lab because
your government was lying to you if you
believe hold on a second hold on a
second the government's job is to uh
only control Behavior right at the cost
of Freedom this starts with an ism it's
the same symptom of that root problem
when you're looking at Maui as we had
with covid as we have with elections you
have to cut off the head of the Beast
don't be led astray by people saying I
just take it on an individual basis well
then you're behind the eight ball and I
say this is the person who makes all
references publicly available I don't
know another show that does it I hope
more people do I think facts matter but
if you don't start off with what is
what is the moral backbone of what I am
arguing here then you are doomed to fail
and dominated by Allah by the way in
most uh emergencies disasters natural
disasters it's not government that bails
you out it's your neighbor it's your
community the First Responders are the
people that live right next to you
almost always yeah and people have to
understand that you got to be a little
bit prepared because a lot of people
think that like a helicopter is going to
land in your backyard not the case
almost always yeah that's just unless
your neighbor is an old helicopter Jim
that well there you go Dr Jim or you're
right next to the White House yes but
other than that uh yeah you're you're
you should be prepared which is why I
always shop at Patriot Supply guys can I
yes
always got some dried food guys yeah I
know how to tie knots and the people who
believe in big government mock you as a
doomsday prepper right look I lived
through the ice storms in Montreal how
many earthquakes right have happened in
California where supplies were low if
you didn't drive outside of your 100
mile radius yeah I've always look have
enough dried food have enough food
that's non-perishable for at least a
month supply of water and a way to heat
it up that is not unreasonable it's the
Democratic part the elites the leftists
who tell you that's just come on what
why do you think we're that we're going
to take care what you think the shit's
gonna hit the fan that scenario I don't
know what's going on in Maui does that
require someone to believe that there's
going to be some kind of digital is it
EMT attack is it ENT
that's right EMP I apologize that's
right so I have a neighbor like Steve
and Stephen I need to borrow your back
your mouth they Mock You somebody's got
to carry on my water oh by the way they
Mock You For Being prepared for exactly
this scenario you should be prepared
it's gonna happen yeah they don't want
strong individuals and communities they
want you dependent on them right and
they should have been prepared from the
government they should have said hey
guys by the way wildfires huge risk
right now because we haven't cut the
grass because we want to do it by the
way yeah there's the overlay of talking
about the deadly threat of wildfires but
also just know Democrats have been in
control I think at every single level of
government for at least a decade there
wow those are the kinds of policies that
this party brings with them it ends up
costing it's Detroit with palm trees
this is why when I work out it's not
about bodybuilding it's about functional
fitness guys it's about running from
fires I hate every word of that phrase
It's just why I'm back dominant guys
it's why my back look at my thighs and
back not much more of this September 1st
the Brian Callan show now
now actually we're looking forward to
the show you're going to have people on
both conversations yes people will have
to try to engage people in debates I'm
gonna have I mean I want to have people
on that I disagree with yeah I'm looking
forward to it you're going to run into a
booking problem after this time it's a
problem that's all right let's see what
happens I can I can I can trick him into
it well it's called sandbagging now
leave Crowder's name out of it
that's always a good call so do we want
to talk we should should we talk about
this here so yeah this is something else
we're talking about the ism while we're
talking about the ideology you know this
is what we do here at mug club and we're
incredibly grateful uh for those of you
who have joined in if you're watching
the free portion on rumble or on YouTube
right now hey none of this happens uh if
you don't support us at lotto.com with
everything that we have there we're
growing we've expanded it it's an
umbrella it's a full-scale network
powered by Rumble but here's why and we
always said we were willing to forego so
some numbers as we transferred from Big
Tech platforms YouTube right to rumble
yeah because Rumble has now reached I
think six percent a few months ago six
percent of the video uh video market
share which is a great thing doesn't
sound like a lot that is huge that's a
huge milestone considering the strength
yes
um and the reason for that is because
these people will always remove you they
promise to kill you last and a lot of
people on the right play ball and the
idea is well I want to reach the
unreached I have always agreed with that
right I've been on YouTube since 2000
six I believe political videos since
2008 believe me I understand it however
we have reached a Tipping Point where
you are precluded on these platforms
from telling the truth and basically
reaching people without the truth is of
no value it's based on a lie even if
you're not lying but at a certain point
the half truth is worse than a lie so
this has now happened with uh Glenn Beck
this week he's been going through it we
have some other examples uh they're able
to throttle you shut you off at any
moment Wednesday afternoon
without warning Apple removed all of
Glenn Beck's shows was this yesterday to
start Tuesday it was yesterday it was
all yesterday this all happened
yesterday man that happened quickly so
they removed all of Glenn Beck's shows
Apple all of them
and we have some issues that have been
going on with apple this very same week
from the podcast platform here let's see
his clip first uh hey we're just uh
sitting here in my office and we're
discussing something that we just saw
um here
um
this is from Apple we found an issue
with your show The Glenn Beck program
which must be resolved before it's
available on Apple podcast your show's
been removed from Apple podcast from the
Apple podcast team they sent us to uh
sent us a link and said for more details
go to the link and the link only says
your show has been removed from Apple
podcasts well we got that one dummy I
I mean I cannot imagine what they are
what they're basing this one I can't I
mean have we even had strikes nothing
right
this is crazy now Crazy by the way
before anyone goes into I you like Glenn
Beck I like none of that matters people
should not be removed period okay I only
ask that everyone out there who
experiences this you know look back to
they do the same for Alex Jones for
ourselves for all these people I don't
care if I agree with them now it doesn't
mean that you have to hire them it
doesn't mean you have to pay them but
you should of course support people as
long as they are not committing a crime
being able to to speak their mind on
these platforms that are protected by
laws as a digital Town Square
the problem there the only problem is a
mindset of I don't think we had any any
strikes by the way we have countless
strikes yeah it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter they're going to do it
anyway get we all need to get out of
that mindset oh well Alex Jones is just
he's too extreme on x y z it doesn't
matter I don't think we had any we've
never said anything that would run a
follow these power it doesn't matter
and I fully support Glenn Beck being
re-platformed it seems like he has been
about four hours later he tweeted that
his episodes were back on they still
don't have answers they were claiming it
was a copyright issue and this is
something new as well retroactively they
can create copyright issues let me tell
you where this is a bigger issue is
investigative journalism for example we
have done changed my Minds where I think
YouTube changed this policy now thank
you mug Club where people gave an
interview gave their name signed a
release and then said I don't like the
way that the interview came across even
though it was unedited went to YouTube
and YouTube said we're going to remove
it because it's a privacy violation I
said it's a single-party consent State
and we have a release which we don't
need doesn't matter that's our policy
they can make up any rule they want to
catch you
and was it this week that as well was it
our our show on Apple you guys can let
me know if you're listening on the audio
version they were only uploaded today
all three episodes all three were
uploaded today even though we were
uploading them people were letting us
know like hey I haven't seen your Apple
uh podcast for the show in the last
couple of days and we're like What yeah
what's no idea why it was up on Spotify
everywhere else that you can get
podcasts just not Apple could just be a
glitch but you'll never know because
there's no transparency and your
government doesn't want to investigate
Ridiculous by the way if you have an
issue like this so just just so you know
how transparent this is we dealt with
this I think with faith Facebook on a
live stream for like the Oscars or
something like that one time where we
went back when we were doing that that
was the first one yeah they did it
immediately they don't have to give you
an explanation so here's here's how it
goes if there is a problem you reach out
and say hey we have a problem please
respond within 24 hours otherwise we're
going to pull all of your stuff down
right that's an easy way to do it hey we
have an issue somebody's saying this can
you give us some more details because
they were saying that our thing we were
just restreaming it it's like no it's
parody I was dressed as a gold statue
you were crying out loud you were a good
old statue it was a very good gold
statue they don't right now they just
remove you because it takes away all of
the momentum but you're saying you you
you're saying there's a way to to are
you saying what to do and I'm saying the
default position shouldn't be to shut
off someone's life immediately
immediately it should be to not to
assume guilt before it's privileged is
that an algorithm though does that
happen automatically I don't care it
doesn't matter they're setting it up
fails so basically if I go I go right
now and I claim something on another
person's show they're going to take it
off immediately now I I don't I'd love
to do an A B test on conservative versus
liberal and see how they handle that
right if I make oh we've done it in the
past yeah but if they make that claim
you have to be able to prove that right
don't take somebody off in the middle of
a live stream because then all of the
viewers go oh I guess they're down I'm
gonna go somewhere else and now you've
lost all that momentum right that's all
they have to do is go oh whoops sorry
you had a claim or oh there's a glitch a
trademark dispute sorry fix it four
hours later yeah those things don't get
resolved in four hours and to people
saying go and create your great join my
club
at least go over to rumble people who
say go and create your own if you don't
first off that's not a valid argument
here because we're talking about section
230 these platforms are created and
they're protected by big government they
are one and the same they are more
powerful than most governments it's not
I don't I don't concede any territory to
that argument but if that's the case
right now even if you don't have a dime
switch from YouTube to rumble
and you should do it for everything that
you possibly can and if you want someone
to create it hey it's the first umbrella
Network ever uh autonomously from a
mainstream platform on Rumble is my club
we have ourselves Alex Jones Nick
depaolo Brian Callan Hodgetwins guns and
gear and we have an investigative unit
and we're going to expand but it only
exists because of people like you the
point is you will always be removed and
they will find a new reason just like
Donald Trump president Trump with the
indictments and they don't need a reason
to ban ideas they don't like if you say
oh Alex Jones is too extreme fine you
say oh Glenn Beck is too extreme which
is absurd to say but fine you don't like
any of those people okay how about Kelly
mcinerney she was locked out of her
Twitter for sharing the New York posts
uh the Biden story The Hunter Biden
story I should say I should clarify what
I'm talking about a piece of crap Biden
the Sun
while she was press secretary not Biden
the Elder it's incredible it's it's her
job Jordan Peterson was suspended from
Twitter
because he had an interview with RFK Jr
that was also removed from YouTube
unbelievable at least I know that's why
I was removed from YouTube I don't know
why it was suspended from Twitter Libs
of tick tock they were removed from
Twitter with no explanations no tweets
were even flagged just for reposting
other posts hey you may say I don't like
Andrew Tate okay but you shouldn't be
removed from all platforms for being a
top G
whatever that OMG I say he's like upper
middle of the pack G I don't know top is
a little bit lofty yeah but he was doing
all right and I can disagree third best
student yes yes
Alex Jones of course still banned from
Twitter
still banned from Twitter and of course
ourselves how many times have we been
suspended like this is something this is
the most important before we get to
mail-in voting before we get to voter ID
just the hunter Biden story would have
changed that last election period it
wouldn't have even been close what do
you think they want to do for the next
election that changes the very future of
your country if you could do that
butterfly effect if you could do the
shitty Back to the Future whichever one
it is where they go to the West they're
all okay they're fine they're all good
whatever I don't need to get sideways
with the Back to the Future people
you would see a parallel world of a
dystopian future that you probably can't
imagine unless this changes and you can
change it right now you have a moment in
time right now where you can say all
right we can migrate somewhere else
that's what we all believe in doing and
they are going to come for you anyway it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if you
are a mainstream conservative Mormon
for crying out loud
polygamy
of course you went there what happened
of course you went there sorry guys this
is a serious show let's keep if you were
to drug test Glenn Beckett would read
why are you here yes
the guy the guy is sweet the guy is not
controversial he just said that himself
he's a decent man the things that he
says are in line with a huge portion of
Americans oh they make up a copyright
reason and then they don't give you an
answer they can always create a reason
they can make it up
do you have anything else you guys want
to know we're actually thinking about
having Dr Robert Epstein I believe is
his name oh I know Robert I've
interviewed him phenomenally he was he
he talks a lot about like you said big
Tech they can just remove you and yeah
before we get to mail-in ballots and
everything else you're right this is the
new the new field of battle essentially
for us right now is to make sure
fine you're not stealing the elections
anymore you're manipulating the election
well Robert Epstein has shown time and
again and by the way Robert scheme is is
a Democrat he's a self-professed Harvard
government but but he has shown over and
over again that Google so for example
the videos that Google will push towards
the youth are I think 98 have a 98 left
leaning uh bias uh but but also the fact
that um I think if you were a Democrat
you saw when when it was time to vote
you got this message that said go vote
yep if you were if you listen to
right-wing radio or whatever you didn't
get that right it's he's done a lot of
research it's kind of it's really
interesting he's in a show called the
creepy line which is basically the
search bar for Google is what they
called it because they're not just
giving you information they're actually
manipulating what you do that changes
elections and a lefty from Harvard who
absolutely would disagree with us on a
ton of issues is saying this is a
problem we need our elections to at
least we need to at least trust that
what happened on Election Day is
accurate yeah we need to trust that and
that nobody's messing with that this is
remember when they were talking about
Cambridge analytica and how it affected
brexit and all that stuff that happened
over there that is Child's Play it's not
even closer to what he's talking about
with Google and those guys Child's Play
yeah well take okay take an example
let's take this company right here
um we're for going many millions of
dollars right in Revenue with just
YouTube and Google but don't get a dime
from that right and that has been and
then Facebook created this this
competitor right where they were saying
oh we're going to compete and then
basically they became they became one
and the same as far there is no
competition really in the ad space right
now and Rumble actually just made a new
announcement regarding this I don't have
the ins and outs of it but you can go
and follow Chris pavlovski on Twitter so
we forego many many millions
okay how many other people out there
like us how many other companies out
there forego many many many millions of
dollars many or even hundreds of
thousands of dollars if they're an
upstart that they could use to amplify
their message oh and by the way they
can't even use the resources they do
have because they're throttled and
they're not allowed to advertise take
this
program multiply it by several hundred
thousand other people out there trying
to do the same thing
on the flip side you get the
right-of-way
you get the express lane if you're a
leftist not only do you get tens of
millions of dollars on YouTube and on
Facebook but you get preferential
treatment so that your stories get
thrust into someone's feet just take
that
see how much you see how much that
shifts the balance this is why appeasing
crocodiles is futile and this is why we
have migrated to rumble nothing would
make me happier than to never have to
broadcast on YouTube ever again right
the closest we can do right now is use
them as long as they are useful and we
don't make a dime uh Stephen Colbert
does though uh yeah every time we run
one of his Clips they get to claim they
get to claim the revenue at any time
they can pull you uh Brian can this is
also something by the way we've had
changed my Minds pulled in the past I
don't know what's going to happen with
the segment
because we did have one of these uh I'm
going to show you here a teaser we'll be
doing a debate live stream on uh on
Wednesday night but Monday this is what
we'll be uh going up as the teaser I'm
about to show you there was one person
to a man you were there who begged to be
on camera oh yeah begged to be honest we
were walking to the car all right we're
done
begged and then when they didn't like
what was happening and this wasn't a
debate yeah uh said I do not consent I
don't consent I don't consent for this
to be useless well it is single party
consent you asked me we had packed up
our camera equipment well then this is
not you'll see this when it comes to you
this is not in line with your company or
its values and you should not be allowed
because these are entitled people who
don't understand the law but what's
going to happen YouTube Facebook are you
going to follow the law
or are you going to follow your own
rules here's the choice that you have to
make if you benefit from the government
with Section 230 as a platform and not a
publisher you better follow the law but
you don't and we always have to do that
we always have to go through this
guessing game everything we've done is
legal it's above board and by the way
it's incredibly productive this is one
out of five conversations where
everything was friendly
but this one person I don't consent
looking at the camera you can't run this
guarantee you they're going to file a
complaint with YouTube and Facebook when
we do run it
it's not something an investigative
journalists should have to worry about
so we are going to go to chat Thursday
if you are not a member at montclair.com
but Monday here's a little taste of what
you'll be seeing is new installment of
black and white whole new segment new
show black and white on the gray issues
are your personal interactions with
white people worse than ever yeah watch
the media today you'd think we're more
divided than ever and I realize that
race issues aren't necessarily depicted
in the same way that people are
experiencing it in real time
so we're gonna go out and talk with
people so we stopped missing each other
this is black and white in the gray
issues
what about the American culture yeah so
you're the great Melting Pot are you
proud to be American right so you think
that in certain areas of 10 you think
that white women are afraid of you I
have to be a bit more Hi how are you and
do you find that then the interaction is
usually positive if you do that yeah
yeah I experience a lot more racism from
the black people than from the white
people well whether you look at like my
qualifications you're like hey what is
it that I do right and do like okay
great you're the best candidate for this
versus like okay cool you got to go what
is the right thing to do to hire based
on race or just higher diversity but
what if they're not the best person
Beyonce can find 14 black turn bonus and
sure you can find one black person to
join your team
I'm like what
[Applause]
[Music]